- Hey guys, I'm Adam Rippon.
I'm here at Buzzfeed, and I'm
here to play a little game.
(chimes twinkling)
- [Announcer] Hello, and
welcome to, How Gay is That?
The game show where we ask celebrities
to tell us how gay an inanimate object is.
Let's do it, here's
your host, Adam Rippon.
- First of all, I'm very hungry.
Avocado toast, this is more
of like, a millennial thing.
Here's the thing, this is
what they're not telling you,
this is what the liberal media
doesn't wanna share with you.
All millennials are gay, every
millennial is a little gay.
And it all started with avocado toast.
From one to 10, avocado toast, 10.
Ugh, this is kale.
See, I have a problem with kale,
because it's the most
disgusting of all the greens.
On a scale from one to
10 this is about a five.
Because if it were gay
it would taste better.
Peaches, we took the peach,
and we repurposed it's symbolism.
Sending a peach emoji is a
great way to ask a friend,
for a butt pic.
What does he (bleep) the peach?
- [Producer] Well, yeah.
- In Call Me By Your Name?
He uses this, oh that's nasty.
On a scale from one to 10,
a peach is about a nine.
Classic.
Oh you know what I always
wished that my clothes
closed from the back like this.
This is just too easy, it's too typical.
A doll doesn't excite me in
the way that it should, six.
This is my club drink of choice.
So this is Buzzfeed, so I
will like have some of this.
This is gay, this just
straight up is like,
homosexual propaganda.
It's not even noon yet.
Nine.
Alright, very funny,
so we have an eggplant.
Ya ya ya, this is an
emoji, it's like so funny,
send it to everybody,
eggplant, cucumber, we get it.
First of all, I don't like eggplants,
I know what it symbolizes,
but I'm just not, going, to go there.
Eggplant, you better step it up, three.
(laughing)
He's so cute, he's so
funny, so nice, has a beard.
These are all the characteristics
of the common homosexual.
Baby you're gay, I know
it, everyone else knows it,
on a scale from one to 10,
Gus Kenworthy, perfect 10.
Well, that was, How Gay is This.
(coughing) Really is a vodka soda.
I just wanna say, thanks so
much, and I'm Adam Rippon.
- [Announcer] Thanks for watching,
and remember, inanimate
objects can't have sexualities.
So, this game is pointless.
(upbeat music)